deutschland deutschland über alles
denn auch
weil sie machen gute beute und wir
zeigen euch wie ihr zuhause alleine
nachbarn können und zwar mit hilfe der
berühmten karton 7 2009
neben von flüchtlingsheim beide besoffen
nach zumkeller scheiße allerdings nicht
warte mal dass deine tochter
das ist der weg der sich nicht mehr
gemeldet hat nach dem schlechten sex
muss uns ich habe sechs jahre lang um
sie gekümmert jetzt bist du dran wie
wusste ich bin dran ab nächste woche
denke ich mir wieder an
du machst etwas zu essen bringt sie ins
bett vor ließen wissen kannst du doch
oder
und sachen zum wechseln ab heute hast du
den pub okay jetzt kann ich werde
abgeschoben
aus einer aus kennst du doch oder stoppt
was ist das ich hab keine ahnung
angeblich meine tochter wie heißt du
sara ich bin sechs du kannst dich nicht
bleiben das geht es da musste ich wieder
mitnehmen
mama witt nach eritrea da ist dass
hitler
darum kommt dann so traurig die flieger
kommt ich traurig guckt nicht traurig
der guckt nachdenklich nachgedacht
früher deutschlands deutschland warum
fragen sie viel scheiße mann das nervt
nazis
cool dass ihr da seid wiederum
beschreibt wie das kommt ja nur scheiße
wie heißt es gute zeiten schlechte
zeiten kennt ihr gutes recht
schlichte wurde
runter wollte
alles gleich und das nächste video das
mit